So when one country intervenes and
another country's civil war,
one of the things that happens is it
extends the war and if you think about
it,
what's happening is you're having more
resources coming into that conflict and
it's bringing in new resources,
bringing a new interests,
basically complicating and complexifying
that war that was already a very complex
war.
There are ways in which intervention
might be good,
which is you're trying to pull the
parties apart,
not trying to pick sides one side,
picking the other side,
um,
and,
and that can sort of stop the killing.
But typically before that happens,
if outside states are getting involved
in a civil war,
it tends to extend it.
So history is mixed on how to best solve
civil wars.
Um,
it turns out that the international
community has a strong proclivity toward
a negotiated settlement.
So you want the parties to both a lay
down their arms and negotiate an end to
the civil war where each of them feels
as if they have a part to play in the
configuration of the new state.
That is the absolute preference that the
international community has.
And it pushes to that we're pushing for
that today in Syria,
Afghanistan,
there's no discussion about negotiating
with the Taliban because we understand
we may not be able to force an,
an end to this war and that the
volleyball and are not going anywhere
and that we might not,
we might have to negotiate with them.
The problem is in order for a negotiated
settlement to,
to resolve a civil war,
uh,
requires both sides to stay absolutely
committed to that and to remain
committed to that for a long time.
And that requires for both sides,
or if it was more than one side,
you can think about the former wars and
Yugoslavia more than one side.
That if they renege on the negotiated
settlement,
that it's going to be harmful to them
and to their interests.
So you want to be thinking about how to
ensure that both sides or all sides feel
compelled to stay aligned with what the
negotiated settlement brought,
uh,
in,
in order to end the war.
And one way to do that as to ensure that
the security service,
that the armed forces are configured
correctly,
and that they're representative of the
broader nation.
Another way is to have outside
peacekeepers there to keep the parties
apart.
So you can think about the former
Yugoslavia or even Cyprus.
There are peacekeepers there and they've
been there now for decades in both
places in Bosnia.
Uh,
they were supposed to be there for one
year.
Bill President,
Bill Clinton said we're only gonna be
there for a year.
And that was in 1995.
It's now 2017.
And similarly in Cyprus,
in the 19 seventies,
peacekeepers were supposed to be there
temporarily and they're,
they're somewhat permanently.
The good news is you haven't had many
deaths as a result because the
peacekeepers have Kevin apart.
So negotiated settlements are one way to
sort of end wars and to keep them w
ended.
But actually they're quite,
they're there,
they're not the most common.
Uh,
an alternative is thinking about
military victories,
which end today about half of civil wars
prior to the end of the Cold War,
ended three quarters of all civil wars.
So a military victory just means that
once I prevails on the battlefield and
it turns out historically that there are
more robust,
that one,
one side winds and prevails and civil
war,
you're more likely to have a longer
lasting settlement.
Uh,
and the question is why is that?
So I've researched that and it turns out
I believe the reason is,
is because to,
to reason,
it turns out that rebel victories or
even more a robust,
uh,
one is,
is that by defeating the other side,
you've demonstrated that you have the
capacity to beat the other side,
right,
that you actually have the military
might.
So when you think about those negotiated
settlements,
that's what a third party is providing,
is the capacity to keep the players
apart.
And secondarily,
particularly when it comes to rebel
victories,
why they're more robust is they have
legitimacy.
So they defeated the government and they
usually can bring the population behind
them to support the configuration and
the running of the new government.
And in fact,
the rebels quite often bring opposition
into government in order to more
effectively govern.
So military victories are an option.
They have been an option historically,
the issue is the international community
sort of doesn't support it because it
sounds as if we're advocating the use of
force or the continued use of force.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm a pragmatist when it comes to these
kinds of things.
I look at the international community,
uh,
and where it wants to go and whether it
wants to go into different corners of
the world and it's not willing to go
into every corner of the world,
the international community,
particularly large actors,
the Soviet Union in the old days,
now Russia and the United States and its
allies aren't going to go everywhere.
So they're not going to commit to
bringing peace to every corner of the
world.
Think about me and mark today and there
were hanging being targeted.
Me and Mara has had a number of civil
wars raging for a number of years,
but the international community does not
have the will to go in there and
negotiate separate pieces to bring peace
to that country.
And therefore we have to acknowledge and
recognize that military victories are
out there.
They have concluded civil wars most
recently.
Um,
they concluded two,
one was Sri Lanka where the government
prevailed over the Tamil Tigers after
decades of fighting.
And now,
yes,
it was a horrific end to that civil war.
There's no denying it.
There were fears of genocide,
but now the international community can
step in and say to the Sri Lankan
government,
you need to treat the Tamil population a
equitably,
fairly justly and,
and perhaps work with the Sri Lankan
government,
uh,
to have them behave,
to not sort of,
um,
take out vengeance a revenge against the
timing of population.
And then the other one is in south Sudan
with south Sudan.
It was actually a rebel victory.
Uh,
and basically that was a rebel victory
that resulted in the partition and the
creation of a new state.
Which again,
partition is quite rare.
The international community doesn't
support the idea of making new states in
part because most states in the
international system are multinational
and multiethnic and they don't want to
set that precedent of allowing one state
to have in one state to allow for pieces
of it to break off because they fear
that it'll set off a set of dominoes,
not only within their own state but what
globally.
So,
so,
um,
victory is a possibility as well as
negotiated settlements.
Uh,
and when I look at these cases
historically,
and then also contemporaneously,
um,
when I'm looking at is,
is there a will and the capacity of the
international community to get involved.
And if there's not,
then we might want to countenance
victory for one side or the other.
Who were the good guys?
Who were the bad guys?
Honestly,
in most of awards is a little bit about,
on both,
on some cases is a lot of bad on one
side,
a little bit about,
on another.
Um,
and so you want to look at,
um,
uh,
the,
the conditions about whether victory is
even a possibility and then negotiate a
settlement.
Is there a commitment from one party,
the United Nations,
a coalition of states to go in and just
help keep the peace or to make peace and
then help keep the peace later?
Because without that commitment,
it's very hard for the parties to not be
susceptible to fighting down the road.
It turns out if you have one civil war,
your chances as the biggest indicator if
you have had a civil war in the past,
your chances of having another civil war
is much greater.